With this kind of activism,
and community investment that typifies the black barbershop,
of course the barbershop is a perfect place
to talk about high blood pressure and other health concerns in the community.
First, the barbershop is not a medical setting,
and so it doesn't have all the negative psychological baggage
that comes along with that.
When you're in a barbershop,
you're in your territory, and you're among friends
who share your history,
your struggle and your health risks.
Second, because the barbershop is a place of connection,
loyalty and trust,
it's a place where you're more open to have a conversation about health
and especially about high blood pressure.
After all,
conversations about high blood pressure have all the elements of great shop talk:
stress and high blood pressure,
food and high blood pressure,
relationships and high blood pressure,
and yes, what it's like to be a black man in America
and high blood pressure.
But you can do more than just talk about high blood pressure
in the barbershop.
You can concretely take action.
Here we have an opportunity to partner with the Denny Moe's of the world
and empower communities to address the health inequities
that uniquely affect it.
When high blood pressure screening expanded from clinics and hospitals
to communities in the 1960s and '70s,
black physicians like Dr. Eli Saunders in Baltimore
and Dr. Keith Ferdinand in New Orleans
were at the forefront of bringing health promotion to community hubs
in urban black neighborhoods.
These pioneers paved the way for my professional journey
with barbershops and health,
which began in Chicago in medical school.
The very first research project that I worked on as a medical student
was to help design healthcare interventions
that would appeal to black men.
We conducted about a dozen focus groups
with a broad cross-section of black men,
and we learned that for them,
being healthy was as much about being perceived as healthy
as it was about feeling healthy,
and that feeling good went hand in hand with looking good.
This work led to the development of Project Brotherhood,
a community clinic founded by Dr. Eric Whitaker
that provided tailored healthcare to black men.
Part of this tailored care
involved having a barber on the premises
to reward the men who came for needed healthcare
with a free haircut,
to let the men know that we, too, valued how they looked
as well as how they felt,
and that what was important to them was also important to us.
But while there's only one Project Brotherhood,
there are thousands of black barbershops
where the intersection of health and haircuts can be cultivated.
The next stop on my journey was Dallas, Texas,
where we learned that barbers were not only willing
but fully able to roll up their sleeves and participate
in delivering needed health services to improve the health of their customers
and their community.
We teamed up with an amazing cadre of black barbers
and taught them how to measure blood pressure
and how to counsel their customers
and refer them to doctors
to help manage high blood pressure.
The barbers were not only willing to do it
but they were damn good at it.
Over a three-year period,
the barbers measured thousands of blood pressures
resulting in hundreds of black men being referred to doctors
for medical care of their high blood pressure.
These barber-doctor partnerships
resulted in a 20 percent increase in the number of men
who were able to achieve target blood pressure levels
and a three-point drop, on average,
in the blood pressure of each participant.
If we were to extrapolate that three point drop
to every single black man with high blood pressure in America,
we would prevent 800 heart attacks, 500 strokes and 900 deaths
from high blood pressure
in just one year.
And our experience with barbershops has been no different in New York City,
where my journey has currently led me.
With an incredible team of diverse research assistants,
community health workers and volunteers,
we've been able to partner with over 200 barbershops
and other trusted community venues
to reach over 7,000 older black men.
And we've offered high blood pressure screening and counseling
to each and every one of them.
Thanks to Denny Moe
and the myriad other barbers and community leaders
who shared the vision of opportunity and empowerment
to make a difference in their communities,
we've been able to not only lower blood pressure
in our participants,
but we've also been able to impact other health indicators.
So what do you see?
What is your barbershop?
Where is that place for you
where people who are affected by a unique problem
can meet a unique solution?
When you find that place, see the opportunity.
Thank you.
(Applause)